ترتبط هذه الجزيرة الصغيرة في إسبانيا
بالبر الرئيسي من خلال مسار ضيق من صنع الإنسان
وقد يتعرف عليها عشاق Game of Thrones على
أنها موطن أسلاف
أم التنانين
Godzilla gotcha التي
يمكن العثور عليها في إقليم الباسك في
إسبانيا وهي موطن ل  كنيسة صغيرة
مكرسة ليوحنا المعمدان ،
الجسر الحجري الضيق الذي يربط
الجزيرة يتكون من 231 خطوة متعرجة
تؤدي إلى أسطورة الكنيسة ،
إذا وصل الزائرون إلى القمة
ودقوا الجرس على الخارج ثلاث
مرات ، فسيكون هناك رغبة  يتم منحها هيكلًا
تم بناؤه لأول مرة على الجزيرة في
القرن التاسع ولكن منذ ذلك الحين
تم تدميره وأعيد بناؤه وتغيير
الأغراض عدة مرات تراوحت استخداماته
من دير إلى العمل كموقع
لسجن الساحرات المتهمين خلال
محاكم التفتيش الإسبانية في الموسم  سبعة
من لعبة Game of Thrones التي لا تزال
تظهر هي Dragonstone مما تسبب
في ارتفاع شعبيتها بشكل صاروخي وتوافد الآلاف من
الزوار على هذا
الموقع المميز من أجل  جمالها أو ربما
ببساطة على أمل أن يلحظوا يومًا
ما لمحة عن Daenerys Targaryen
[موسيقى]